Salut !
Il y a quelque chose que
j'adorais faire en 2016,
quand j'ai lancé
ma chaîne YouTube.
C'était de vous expliquer
un truc de mentalisme,
que vous seriez capable de
refaire dès la fin de la vidéo.
Et en parlant à Loïc, il a dit :
- Eh beh pourquoi
t'en referais pas un ?"
- Et là moi j'ai répondu :
- Oui, c'est pas faux.
Du coup, il a cru que
j'avais pas compris
et ça c'est un autre problème.
Aujourd'hui je vais débloquer
un truc dans votre cerveau,
qui va vous permettre de réciter
l'alphabet à l'envers comme ça.
Z, Y, X, W, V, U, T, S, R, Q, P, O, N,
M, L, K, J, I, H, G, F, E, D, C, B, A.
Ou en prenant une lettre
de chaque côté comme ça.
A, Z, B, Y, C, X, D, W, E, V, F, U, G,
T, H, S, I, V, R, J, Q, K, P, L, O, M, N.
C'est quelque chose que savent faire
pas mal de mentalistes.
Et je suis toujours étonné
à quel point le public est impressionné
quand je fais ça sur scène.
Viktor Vincent le fait également à une
vitesse assez hallucinante d'ailleurs.
Et à quoi ça sert ?
Excellente question Michel !
A rendre le cerveau plus flexible.
Et à maîtriser l'information
dans tous les sens.
- Et à se la raconter un peu.
- Oui, c'est pas faux.
- Et juste avant de passer
à la première étape,
prenons 60 secondes,
pour parler d'un jeu vidéo
qui est en partenariat
avec cette vidéo, aujourd'hui.
Bonjour, je suis le professeur Fabien
et j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui...
Je vais pas tenir l'accent.
D'un nouveau remède contre l'ennui,
le légendaire Tank shooter,
World of Tanks Blitz !
World of tanks Blitz est un MMO
multiplateforme et gratuit,
pour des combats de tanks
qui déchirent ton ennui.
Avec plus de 120 millions
de joueurs dans le monde,
c'est testé et approuvé.
Et si vous aimez avoir le choix,
le jeu propose plus de 369
véhicules uniques et exclusifs.
C'est à dire 370.
Allant des chars historiques
aux chars expérimentaux,
d'univers un peu comme
Warhammer 40 000, Mad Max.
Vous trouverez le tank
qui vous fera vibrer de plaisir.
Phrase cheloue.
Bataille en sept fois sept,
avec différents modes
dans plus de 25 emplacements.
Des évènements en jeu,
des événements spéciaux
comme l'invisibilité
dans Mad Games,
ou les batailles réalistes
en mode très difficile.
Et là Loïc, tu te demandes :
Quelle est la composition
de World of Tanks Blitz ?
- Bah oui, exactement.
- Merci de poser
la question, c'est sympa.
Des graphismes spectaculaires,
un système de progression
ultra développé,
un team Play pour créer
des pelotons avec vos amis
et participer à des tournois.
La possibilité de changer
d'armes à feu, d'équipements,
même de camouflages.
Le tout pour un gameplay
compétitif, stimulant,
qui vous permettra d'utiliser
pleins de tactiques différentes
pour foncer vers la victoire.
Parce que oui,
on va pas se mentir,
faire exploser des trucs
et détruire les chars des ennemis,
ça vous envoie un sacré
shot de dopamine.
Alors téléchargez World of tanks Blitz
via mon lien à moi, ci-dessous.
Et obtenez un compte
premium de sept jours,
le tank niveau IV, AC 1 Sentinel.
Et un camo "demon's soul".
Sans oublier que jusqu'au 6 mars,
vous pouvez choper le defender MK1,
vous le voyez
actuellement à l'écran.
C'est une tuerie de char
britannique de rang 8
avec un gameplay dynamique,
une tourelle blindée
et un tambour
à chargement rapide.
Tu sais pas ce que ça veut dire,
mais bientôt tu sauras.
Bref en téléchargeant ce jeu,
vous lutterez très efficacement
contre votre propre ennui,
en vous amusant gratuitement
n'importe où, entre amis.
Passez directement
par mon lien dans la description,
ça soutient la chaîne
et les autres projets
comme matière grise,
par exemple.
Etape numéro une,
comment réciter l'alphabet à l'envers ?
Loïc, générique !
Cette étape là, je vais la faire
avec vous et Poisson Fécond.
Pour vous remettre
dans le contexte,
j'ai tourné une vidéo
sur la chaîne de Poisson Fécond
et il nous restait
moins de dix minutes
avant que je parte
pour prendre mon train.
Et je me suis dit, si après
une journée de tournage,
j'arrive à lui faire apprendre
à faire ça en speed
alors c'est que tout le monde
peut le faire et j'en fais une vidéo.
Du coup Chris, ma question c'est :
Est-ce que tu peux
me réciter l'alphabet
le plus vite possible,
s'il te plait ?
- A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I, J, K, L, M,
N, O, P, Q, R, S, T, U, V, W, X, Y, Z.
Yes.
- On est sur un succès.
- Du coup, challenge conclu.
- T'as bien compris,
le sujet de la vidéo c'est maintenant,
Est-ce que on peut le dire à l'envers,
pas forcément à la même vitesse.
Mais au rythme que tu veux.
Essaye de le dire à l'envers.
- Z, Y, W, X...
- Donc tu as déjà inversé,
parce que le X est avant le W.
Il y des années, quand j'ai voulu
apprendre à le faire moi-même.
J'ai dû inventer une méthode.
Et c'est cette méthode là
que je vous donne aujourd'hui.
Alors l'alphabet
est composé de 26 lettres.
- Merci Fabien.
- De rien Loïc.
Apprendre 26 lettres c'est long.
Mais si on les regroupe par quatre,
ça nous fait plus que
six choses à apprendre.
On n'a pas commencé à le faire,
qu'on a déjà gagné
énormément de temps.
- Ouais, alors, excuse moi,
mais quatre fois six, ça fait 24.
- Exact, il reste donc
les deux dernières lettres, B et A.
Je pense qu'il y a pas besoin
de l'apprendre pour s'en souvenir.
Le premier paquet
à connaître c'est ZYX.
Allez-y, dites le.
ZYX.
Mais comme on fonctionne par quatre,
il faut se dire ZYXW.
Essayez d'imaginer
le mot dans votre tête.
Voyez-le écrit ZYXW.
Et prononcez le,
deux-trois fois à voix haute.
Et... Et boum c'est ancré.
Et pour le réciter,
vous pensez à ZYXW
et vous avez juste à l'épeler.
Z, Y, X, W.
Et là vous venez
de faire le plus dur.
Le deuxième paquet,
il est easy de fou !
Vous dites VUTS.
Et c'est bon.
En fait c'est VUT au pluriel.
C'est super simple à retenir,
V, U, T, S.
VUTS.
Maintenant vous connaissez
ZYXW, VUTS, que vous pouvez épeler.
- Z, Y, X, W, V, U, T, S.
- Troisième paquet.
C'est le plus marrant.
C'est, R, Q, P, O.
Alors j'ai un moyen mnémotechnique
que vous ne pouvez pas oublier.
Pour RQPO.
Si je mets de l'air
dans le cul,
Alors je fais un pet, haut.
Alors oui je sais, c'est débile.
Mais plus le cerveau
imagine des trucs chelous
et mieux il les retient.
Alors vous, vous souvenez de l'air
dans le cul, ça fait un P, O.
Et visualisez RQPO
et dites le à voix haute.
Une ou deux fois.
Prenez le temps, faites pause
si vous voulez.
Et vous connaissez maintenant
ZYXW, VUTS, RQPO.
- Z, Y, X, W, V, U, T, S...
R, Q, P, O.
- Parfait.
- Très bien.
- Vous connaissez maintenant,
la moitié de l'alphabet à l'envers.
C'est énorme !
La vidéo vient de commencer.
Comme d'habitude,
il suffit de l'épeler pour le réciter.
Et juste un détail.
Apprendre à dire une lettre du début
et de la fin de l'alphabet.
A, Z, B, Y, C, X, D, W, etc.
Est encore plus facile.
Et ça on verra ça
après rapidement.
Quatrième paquet.
Ce sont des nems laqués.
Nems laqués.
N, M, L, K.
Et voilà le nouveau paquet, NMLK
pour ZYXW, VUTS,
RQPO, et NMLK.
Avant dernier paquet,
c'est JIHG.
En général, les gens
pensent à un gigot,
en essayant de se rappeler
que le H est avant le G,
puisqu'on fait à l'envers.
Poisson Fécond,
il s'est amusé à associer
le nem que l'on fourrait
dans le gigot.
Et c'est tellement bizarre,
que c'est une idée excellente.
JIHG.
Vous avez maintenant
en tête un truc chelou,
mais surtout ZYXW, VUTS,
RQPO, NMLK, JIHG.
- Bon, Z, Y, X, W, V, U, T, S...
R...
R,P ?
- Tu le mets où le R ?
- R, Q, P, O, N, M, L, K.
Ensuite on a le finish, évidemment
celui qu'on aime tous.
C'est J, I, H, G.
- Très bien.
- JIHG.
- Là ça commence à être compliqué,
parce que tu l'apprends en trash.
Et le dernier...
- Jekyll Trash.
- Jekyll trash !
- On l'aime tous.
Et avant de passer à la toute fin,
on va laisser votre cerveau
digérer un petit peu.
Pour l'information
faut qu'il la synthétise.
Pendant ce temps, je vous laisse
la liberté de vous abonner.
Et d'activer la cloche,
pour voir les prochaines vidéos.
C'est le bon moment là, voilà.
Et puis peut-être aussi,
vous abonner à mon Instagram.
Comme ça on va peut-être atteindre
les 300 000 personnes
qui voient le contenu que je fais
exclusivement pour Instagram,
comme Caféine.
Voilà.
Et c'est déjà la fin.
Le dernier paquet avec FEDC.
Alors FEDC.
C'est du feu
qui provoque un décès.
FEDC.
Feu-décès.
Les trois derniers paquets,
ça donnerait donc un nem laqué,
que l'on fourre dans un gigot.
Il prend feu
et c'est le décès.
Soit NMLK, JIHG, FEDC.
Et bien sûr on rajoute B, A à la fin,
pour terminer parce que...
- C'est la fin.
- C'est fini, oui c'est ça.
On récapitule
ZYXW, VUTS, RQPO,
NMLK, JIHG, FEDC, BA.
- Z, Y, X, W, V, U, T, S,
R, Q, P, O, N, M, L, K...
J, I, H...
G, F, E, D, C, B, A.
- Exact !
C'est un strike.
Monsieur Chris,
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
ce défi là dans mon décor.
Et moi je vais vous
donner des pistes,
si vous voulez faire des trucs
encore plus ouf avec l'alphabet.
Parce que c'est possible.
Mais pour ça on se rejoint
dans mon bureau.
Monsieur Chris.
- Un plaisir Monsieur Olicard.
- Je vous ai fécondé...
Le cerveau !
Passons à l'étape numéro deux.
Réciter l'alphabet en prenant
une lettre du début de l'alphabet,
et une lettre
de la fin de l'alphabet.
Loïc, mini générique !
Très joli mini générique.
Alors ça c'est très rapide,
car à partir de la lettre F,
il n'y a plus qu'une seule
chose à retenir.
Le but est donc à la fin de faire,
A, Z, B, Y, C, X, D, W,
E, V, F, U, G, T, H, S, I, R,
J, Q, K, P, L, O, M, N.
La première étape c'est,
A, Z, B, Y, C, X, D, W, E, V.
C'est la première chose à retenir.
Et il faut retenir,
les lettres deux par deux.
C'est beaucoup plus simple
pour le rythme.
Alors A, Z, c'est facile,
parce que c'est logique.
La première et la dernière
lettre de l'alphabet.
B, Y, c'est pas plus compliqué.
On le voit, on le visualise.
CX, vous pouvez vous rappeler de la
vieille voiture qui s'appelait une CX.
Donc CX comme CX.
DW et EV, eux sont à retenir.
C'est le seul effort à faire.
Et encore c'est très facile,
quand on connaît déjà
l'alphabet à l'envers.
Donc DW, EV.
C'est même sûrement
l'étape la plus difficile.
La suite, elle est
incroyablement simple,
j'ai l'impression que
c'est fait exprès, c'est...
J'étais HS moi, hier.
J'étais HS, hier Loïc.
Et toi, t'es en forme ?
- Ouais, tranquille ouais !
- Moi j'étais HS.
- Mais en fait hier
c'est parce que...
Non mais, c'est l'exemple Loïc.
Tu craques un peu trop vite Loïc.
"Fu", j'étais HS hier.
C'est FU, F,U.
GT HS IR.
On dirait vraiment que
c'est fait pour ça quoi.
Le prochain après,
à retenir c'est JQ.
ça vous pouvez trouver
un moyen mnémotechnique,
ou juste le retenir comme ça.
Et après il reste qu'un truc à retenir,
qui est très facile aussi.
C'est CAPELO AMEN.
Alors CAPELO,
comme maître Capello.
Maître Capello.
Maître Capello, ça fait KPLO.
Et amen, ça fait MN.
Tu vois, Capello Amen.
KPLO MN.
Et c'est terminé en fait.
Vous venez de le faire là,
entièrement.
C'est terminé.
A, Z, B, Y, C, X,
comme la voiture, D, W, E, V.
"Fu', j'étais HS hier,
F, U, G, T, H, S, I, R.
J, Q et maître Capello amen.
KPLO, MN.
Soit,  A, Z, B, Y, C, X, D, W, F, E, V,
F, G, T, H, S, I, R, J, Q, K, P, L, O, M, N.
Mesdames et messieurs,
vous savez donc maintenant
réciter l'alphabet à l'envers,
comme Poisson Fécond.
D'ailleurs, je vous invite également
à découvrir sa chaîne
et ses vidéos qui sont très très
intéressantes, drôles, instructives.
Vous avez un lien
dans la description.
Vous savez dire l'alphabet à l'envers
et vous savez aussi dire l'alphabet
en prenant la première
et la dernière lettre à chaque fois.
Et ça vraiment, c'est très stylé.
Question à 2000.
Est-ce que vous aimez
ce genre de vidéos ?
Si vous en voulez d'autres,
vous me dites dans commentaires.
Mais dites-moi surtout,
ce que vous voulez apprendre
dans les commentaires.
C'est ça qui m'intéressera le plus.
Et si c'est pas encore fait,
il vous reste quelques secondes
pour liker cette vidéo
et vous abonner.
Merci à World Of Tanks Blitz
d'avoir sponso cette vidéo.
Ce partenariat permet de financer
les projets comme Matière Grise.
Donc c'est très cool
pour soutenir la chaîne,
vous téléchargez
le jeu gratuitement,
en cliquant sur mon lien à moi,
dans la description.
Voilà pour terminer,
vous pouvez regarder cette vidéo
qui vous apprendra autre chose.
Ou celle-ci aussi qui est
vraiment très très cool.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !
- Bisous.
- Ah c'était mignon,
comme une petite loutre.
Tu sais pourquoi elles ont
une poche sur le ventre ?
Pour mettre leurs
petits cailloux préférés.
C'est trop mignon.
Oh petit cailloux préféré...
Ciao, ciao...